two welcome everybody to the h3 podcast
number
727 don't be don't flatter yourself
number 27 in the united states 5.5 on
wiki feet
i am your host the fresh prince of dead
air
today's episode is sponsored by honey
and ridge wallets
now i'm not exaggerating when i say
today we've got a heck of an episode
ian is finally coming back after the
break with a powerpoint that he's been
working on
for months um we've never done anything
like this on the show so you definitely
want to stick around for that
before that i do want to slam a little
bit of a
gerd gang in the house now cody cole was
on the podcast recently
and i was trying to explain to him why
i'm constantly coughing why am i such a
mess
and um i said i've got gerd which has
got i don't even notice stands for
gastric
esophagus i swear to god reflux disease
it's a disease
one of my many diseases
so somebody was kind enough to to
represent the gerd gang with a
sick remix so
it's really good by uh pigeon music
[Music]
music
[Music]
oh my my girls
[Music]
it's what you call the acid reflux
disease that i have dirt is hard
[Music]
how many are people in the chat
[Music]
all right what else we got um so
basically i'm torn are we super troopers
are we gerd gang
guard you think we're in
the there days are over that's true we
gotta
we gotta let the fupa days go we gotta
embrace the gerd i don't want the gerd
days either though
i don't want either of them to be honest
can we just be healthy and normal
people gang nah no no one is listening
to that podcast
is anyone healthy and normal
are any of you guys healthy and normal
like just don't be shy like
if you think you're healthy and normal
tell me us
yeah you guys i'm fairly normal dan
you're not normal
you're not next
i haven't slept yet so yeah you're
[ __ ] up zach
zach are you healthy and wrong i think
so yeah yeah i think exactly yeah
normal crippling anxiety you have
crippling anxiety
other than crippling anxiety yeah
other than that i'm fine
you take anything for that uh i got
prescribed something but
i haven't taken it yet what do you got
zoloft
yeah you're [ __ ] up
i mean no offense but i'm just like
anxious to take the anxiety medication
no i was there yeah we were yeah but
from our experience i would say just
take it and worst case
stop taking it yeah you could always
stop taking it
dan you think you're healthy and normal
huh
i guess you have any diseases i got no
diseases
no that i know of
well you would know about it if it was
if it was bad
so dan has no diseases he's in a steady
relationship
he's got parents that are are seem to be
like normal
and productive yeah good parents right
good good childhood yeah they're pretty
cool yeah my childhood
was pretty great hands on some king [ __ ]
that was a sound bite right because i
don't see why ian would say that
and really i think it was down by a fan
no no way dan tell me are you
um how often do you talk to your parents
uh at least once a week i mean
that's weird why is that weird
what do you mean well when i was in
college i would go like months without
talking to them
uh yeah i mean is that funny
it's kind of funny because i used to go
a lot longer without talking to them
i've actually been talking to them more
now that we're in uh in the era of covid
ironically
i don't know just checking in just on
zoom calls or whatever you care about
your parents do you love them
no i think no i don't i don't give a
[ __ ] about my pants yeah of course i do
yeah wow i think
i think dan might be an a normal guy a
normal healthy guy i feel pretty normal
i don't know
you used to vape hard but you kicked it
i mean that's pretty incredible
wow we got interesting we got a normal
healthy guy over here
yeah so you get the award ian i know
you're [ __ ] up i'm not even gonna ask
you
maybe our new ad he doesn't he sleeps
like three hours a day so i mean that's
you must have some kind of undiagnosed
sleeping disorder eh or maybe you do
have it diagnosed but that seems
that this is yeah no i haven't been
professionally diagnosed but
i definitely believe i do you might want
to check that out if you're getting so
exhausted and stuff i mean
sleeping is is an important function
yeah
i agree fighting demons in my sleep like
every night now
oh boring so ian i don't know if you
guys heard but
ian kicked so sam i think sam moved into
you and you just like
the sleepwalking monster i mean you you
were a sleepwalker but like it got much
worse right since she moved in i think
because someone's telling me i'm doing
it
like i might have been doing that the
entire time but i had no feedback on it
oh interesting that's crazy so yeah
how frequently are you sleepwalking
maybe like four times a week holy [ __ ]
so do you actually sleep well though or
do you wake up tired
i i wake up pretty refreshed but i have
vague memories of
the sleepwalking usually it's like i
think there are giant
spiders in my room and i like
throw covers and i like jump out of bed
it's it's intense the other the other
night
sam woke up and i was just like intently
like staring at something she was like
what are you looking at
and i was like nothing and i i remember
this happening i thought i saw like a
giant snake in the room oh my god just
slithering around are you just trying
not
to freak her out so you're like nothing
yeah i was like she's she
no sudden movements i don't see anything
but in my head i saw like a big snake in
the room
so i don't know if you guys recall but
ian like kicked the wall really hard and
broke his foot
recently your foot's all healed up but
you're keep
sleepwalking is sam like totally freaked
out by
by you being up every night looking for
monsters to fight
no she's used to it she's i mean she
does a good job calming me down
and getting me back back into bed and
then i put my belt back on
oh my god well the belt's not doing any
damn good
ian's strapped to the bed now like how
is that
you unbuckle like how do you get out
yeah so i think it does help because
usually these like
i don't know if you call them night
terrors or whatever they last like maybe
40 to 60 seconds and i spend some time
trying to get out of the buckle um and
by the time i get it all undone
take the whole thing off get up then
usually i'm still
in that zone for maybe 20 seconds and
then i realize what i'm doing and go
back to bed
you wake up by the time you get out yeah
so i think it slows me down a little bit
maybe you need another buckle maybe two
buckles
maybe a straight jacket so you have one
buckle around your waist that just
connects to the bed
yeah it goes under the mattress and then
i loop it around and click it in
and then yeah it's it's i'm like
strapped down to the mattress so do you
have to sleep on your back
can you sleep on your side there's
there's a little bit of leeway
i have to like pull it and then i can
roll over
does sam sleep on top of the belt yeah
does that it doesn't bother her no and
she actually likes that because
if i'm pulling at it or i'm doing
something it alerts her and then she
comes
out she calls me down she's a great one
isn't she yeah
that's awesome she's fantastic i'm glad
that she's helping
yeah she's helping you through that that
sounds scary
are you do you ever worry that you'll
hurt her or yourself when you're
sleepwalking
no not her because i think that i'm
i have enough sense to you know
recognize that that's like a never ever
thing that i've never won you still know
who she is even though you're
asleep yeah all of my little things i do
are related to trying to protect myself
or her
i'm like oh there's these giant spiders
we gotta get i pulled her out of bed the
other day
oh my god is she tired all the time
though because i guess you're well
rested but what about her being woke up
in the middle of the night every night
i mean who cares she doesn't complain
no no she she says she's okay she finds
it funny
like sam i saved your life dude why are
you not more grateful
[Laughter]
no she said she'll talk to me and i
don't remember it
i wonder if you confess weird stuff to
her i know she can like really get into
my
psyche and i wouldn't know damn you
better
so interesting you better cherish that
girl she's she's a
keeper no you're you're absolutely right
she is so so is there any way
like to treat this besides just like
nailing your ass to the floor every
night i did a whole sleep study i had i
talked to
specialists and the only thing he said
was
uh try melatonin that's it did you try
melatonin
i tried it and it helped so i'm kind of
alternating and taking it
now and again to see how effective it is
why not just take it every night
well i want to see if it actually helps
which i think it i think it does
we just started doing that i used to
take melatonin to help me sleep it works
great i mean
for me it was like a miracle it just
knocked me out
the only thing was the the nights i take
it the next morning i'm so
groggy yeah that's why i stopped dude
yeah it's kind of tough i tried it one
time and that's exactly what i felt
just foggy all morning one one thing i
was worried about when you told me about
that is like
behind you is a window then
that's like on the third floor or
something right
no my old place was and that panicked me
a lot and i had
gone out there a couple times on the
balcony when i was sleepwalking that's
dangerous um that's [ __ ] scary yeah
yeah but actually now we kind of have
set up this thing in my room where
if i try to go the door to get out of
the room we have things in the way that
will make noise
if i like bang over them so she's got to
sprint to you but i've never tried to
like
you know exit so i think we're fine and
we're way
closer to the to the ground level that's
in the new place
we got to get like a bungee hook it to
the floor and then like hook it to your
back so that
if you try to walk too far away from the
bed it just yanks your ass back i need
like a
like a bell around my couch
as well yeah holy [ __ ] yeah
that's pretty crazy so as to your
original question yeah a little [ __ ]
up
yeah you know you used to have a tremor
when you started but i feel like it's
gone away
i mean i haven't seen you we probably
don't see you enough yeah i still have
it i
i take medication though so that is it
just a random tremor kind of like what
bobby described
or is it something no it's the same
thing essential tremor i mean like you
actually if i hold my hand up it looks
fine or what's a little shaky i mean
yeah i mean and i'm taking stuff so
sometimes you can get a little bad i
think people notice it now and again if
i like reach up and fix my hair i'm kind
of like
shaky but it definitely helps the stuff
i take
so ian it's good to hear from you yeah
but the chat guys
there's no sound bites that entire time
zach what the hell what are you doing
back still
yeah it was i was you know letting you
uh
talk and i mean it's it's a heartwarming
story
thank you i do want to ask you guys your
story
i appreciate that thank you i i do want
to ask because i'm kind of a sick [ __ ]
but do you ever get kinky with like the
bed strap thing zach this is
take it to only fans dude wait how would
that even work i mean it's just a strap
what can you do with it
how you down or some [ __ ] you know well
you could do that without the bed strap
have you ever been tied down
zach uh yes i have actually
zach have you read nas yes i have i
think we've already covered that we did
this cover territory right okay yeah and
did she shower directly before was the
heat of the moment
after a hike no [ __ ] way are you
kidding me
no i'm not kidding what you ate ass
after a hike bro
holy [ __ ] yeah how did it taste
fantastic holy [ __ ] that's why i'm
saying i'm a sick [ __ ] [ __ ]
dude ate ass after a hike was it a hot
day
you ate the poopoo
yeah um no it was a you know it was a
nice temperature 75 degrees
okay that doesn't matter it's a [ __ ]
hike did you
ask could you tell if she wiped really
good before or not
oh my god yeah yeah yeah yeah there was
no poop
no no poo-poo not even like residual
probably a little residual
definitely residual it was it was you
know just like an an ass smell you know
it's like a good ass smell hey [ __ ] it i
mean what's that
i mean no i think i think why not you
know what i think
ask him yeah god bless him i think
there's a lot of women that
that are like appreciate that he's
willing to do that yeah
yeah i mean a lot not but a lot yes yeah
you should put it on your tender profile
i will eat ass after a hike i will eat
i will eat your ass after i guess
i hate it incredible stuff guys
uh this is ian trying to deliver food
but then he got
sleepwalks
i'm trying to make it applicable because
i love it
dan liked it damn people are so
unexpected
yeah thank you i love that having dan
here he laughs and i feel so funny
dan you would make a great girlfriend in
that regard a great girlfriend too why
just because like such explosive i would
feel so funny around him all the time oh
to you yeah cause you know when they say
i've heard this you can tell me
if it's right you can tell a girl's into
you if she's laughing at all your jokes
yeah i mean sure is that a good um
indicator
maybe not because she's lying but she's
just happy to be around you
oh she's i mean or but would you force
yourself to laugh if you were around a
guy you liked
no but i guess you'll probably see it in
different land
lands yeah like you're like oh yeah
you're just being flirty right you're
smiling you're laughing yeah
so dan would make a really good
girlfriend i would feel very happy and
funny all the time well
listen if it doesn't work out between
you guys well with eli number
i'll tell you with ela i have to
i'm like doing a batting with weights on
you know what i mean
you're like i've got i'm operating at a
handicap but it makes me funnier
because you're a tough cookie you're a
tough kid right
okay if i come out with with jokes like
this
if i come out with jokes like this ian
uh keep walking with food
you think i'm gonna get a giggle from
ela hell no
hell no not funny right
so anyway don't say anything i'm just
kidding around but come on you know you
what what is this why are we fighting
now i'm just trying to talk about bella
thorne scamming people for titties
oh can we give everyone an update that i
have a secret drawer
now for the snacks oh yes
continuing on last week's after dark
we got into a somewhat heated debate
because i said you know if i was an
alcoholic
you would have no problem hiding your
alcohol from me
not even hiding but just putting it out
of sight but like when i go ela
you know i've caught a problem with food
and you've got like the most insane
snacks out
and i when i ask you maybe to put it
somewhere else because it's not good for
me
you says you just got to control
yourself and i was like imagine saying
that to an
addict it would feel it would it would
be it would feel crazy
i was only merely trying to say that as
a point as an interesting observation
not really an attack on you
but regardless eila did smoove all of
her drawers or snacks into a drawer
and i have to tell you i've been doing
really well nice yeah
i know where they are it's just it's not
in my face every time i go in the
pantry yeah cool
because i'll go in there to like get
beans or pasta or whatever cooking
dinner right
and then all of a sudden it's like oh a
panda surprise
it's like these little cookies with
chocolate in the middle little pandas
pokey got it it's like dude i'll just
take one pokey
and then all of a sudden one is five
because there's there's so little i'll
go
it's only like 30 calories per pokey
then i eat a whole pack
and it's like 300 calories to my [ __ ]
dome and empty calories
haha [ __ ] i'm laughing because you big
mad
[Music]
all right let's actually talk about bell
ela how much to how much would
first of all bella thorne made two
million dollars
in like one week so my question for you
ela is
would you show your titties for two
million
hmm two million bucks
it's a lot of money but i probably
wouldn't but
because i could technically right
yeah of course yeah of course it's an
interesting question yeah it's not like
it's not like hypothetical yeah real
question
oh that i don't know if people are gonna
pay as much as bella thorne probably not
yeah probably not
but but then it's like you have to keep
com it's a commitment right the
only fans it's not like here's my tits
give me two million bucks
yeah but would you
well i'm not doing it i guess dancers
know no but
um i don't i've not i mean good for them
for everyone on the only face well she
didn't show her tits that's the problem
but i was just curious what were your um
because people keep waiting for our sex
tape and
i still don't know who wants to watch
that but sex tape how much
billion billion dollars
billionaires shouldn't exist either so
let's not give those this is like all
pay for it so anyway bella thorne
she apologizes for ruining only fans
i gotta say it's pretty incredible that
bella thorne came in
and [ __ ] up the entire platform
it's incredible that she was able to do
this because a lot of people were
complaining like
this girl is hollywood she's mainstream
she's coming in and
taking advantage of our platform and at
first i thought they were overreacting
and being a little bit ridiculous but it
turns out she really did
she made two million dollars record
breaking by far
but in response to the amount of
chargebacks and refund requests people
got because she did not deliver
on her claim that they would be fully
nudes
is they capped tipping to a hundred
dollars
and pay-per-view charges to fifty
dollars
and extended in some uh countries
the waiting period to transfer funds up
to 30 days
so i can imagine you know for a lot of
girls that probably
limits the amount of income they can
make
which is crazy because it just gives you
a little um glimpse into what's going on
and only fans
like i mean 50 to 100 sound like a good
tip but
yeah 100 tip well dude if you put a
candle in your ass and light it i mean
i'm expecting a bigger tip than a
hundred okay some requests get out there
right
so at a certain point 100 is not enough
hilo
but um right zach
right zach you were in
have you beat off to her only fans be
honest there's nothing on there dude
no wonder even wants their money back
yeah i mean i sub
unsubbed that [ __ ] i mean disappointment
she gave me crazy instead of blue balls
she gave me bell balls
bell balls why like blue ball it was a
bad joke
oh belle [ __ ] me bella balls ella balls
you know you think if you brought in
that much money you would be like [ __ ] i
gotta go show my butthole or something
because people are gonna bounce you know
what i mean like you gotta deliver on
two million bucks
she's gonna show her titties yeah you
gotta deliver
so anyway she charged two hundred
dollars for a nude photo
which was a purchase uh sent via only
fans causing a torrent of refund
requests
because she was full she was [ __ ]
clothed in the pic
i mean what the [ __ ] now can someone
explain this
the nude offer may have come from an
imitation account
yeah i don't know what the [ __ ] does
that mean last time too and um
i i tried to research it some more and
couldn't really find a definitive answer
about it but
yeah she as far as i've seen she hasn't
denied it which seems like
that would be an obvious thing to deny
since she's getting so much heat so i'm
leaning towards it being legitimate i
think it has to be legitimate and
there's all
as we're gonna discuss uh she she seems
to be
willing to uh lie about some other
things as well so i wouldn't really put
it past her i guess okay
uh here we go this is her apology
she was doing this to remove the stigma
behind sex
sex workers and the negativity that
surrounds the word sex
by bringing a mainstream face to what's
what i was trying that's what i was
trying to do to help
bring more faces to the site to create
more revenue [ __ ]
you made two hundred dollars you didn't
even show your titties and if you really
cared you would have donated it to
charity and then nobody would be angry
she got paid dude come on yeah
i wanted to bring attention to sight the
more people on the site the more likely
a chance of normalizing the stigma
there's already a lot of people on the
side
yeah yeah exactly only fans is like a
mainstream meme at this point although
i have risked my career a few times to
remove the stigma behind sex
work yeah but you didn't even show
titties i mean what's the risk
right what was it zach what what was it
why were
wh why were these photos behind a
paywall what did you see
it was literally just [ __ ] she'd post on
her instagram and then she did like a
a vogue you know those vogue 73 question
thing
she did like an intro video like that
for the only fans
yeah it was just [ __ ] dude it was
just regular
content yeah like not even like a thong
or
lingerie or anything it's bikini and
i mean you see some nip but that's about
it like like through the bikini
um yeah um but no dude i mean you can
find that [ __ ] on instagram
oh my god
that's how would you call that sex work
yeah exactly i think this apology just
dude that's not sex work dude
it's a paid [ __ ] instagram that's
what that was
i'm a mainstream face yeah you've said
that she keeps saying that it's like
you're flattering yourself
i'm a mainstream face when you have a
voice a platform you try to use it in
helping others that's why i made two
million dollars in pocketed
it advocating for something bigger than
yourself again this is a process that
hurt you and that i'm truly sorry
p.s i'm meeting with the only fans about
the new restrictions to find out why
and now she's like i'm the savior i'm
gonna save and fix everything
this is [ __ ] up i'm sorry yadda yadda
send me your links and a pic and i can
promote you guys yeah
[ __ ] lame weird that's a that's just
an apology written by like a pr
ah agency too many like weird
grammatical
mistakes because i'm mainstream and
i'm a mainstream face and i'm just so
famous and popular i thought i could
bring more people to your website
and i did do that but uh i destroyed the
whole platform in the process and i
didn't really show titties but i was
just trying to help the sex workers
dude there's girls in there taking can
burning candles up their ass
you want to talk about sex work god i
love her
who the burning candle lady or the fake
nudes
it's gotta be guys right
yeah we can infer that it was the candle
yeah
so this is when it gets a really weird
wrinkle in the story in an
interview with the la times thorne said
she was working she was on only fans as
a research for a documentary
with director sean baker
she said it's a feature we are
researching as i'm living it currently
she shared but then baker this director
uh immediately put out a statement
saying i am
not attached to this project
it's a really weird lie to say because
he's like i love that
so he tweeted this out immediately he
said i would like to make it
very clear that the news of me making a
film about only fans using bella thorne
as research is false
i am not attached to this project i'm
actually in development on two features
that i put years of research and love
into
and neither of these films have anything
to do with mrs thorne or
only fans earlier this month i had a
conversation with her
and discussed a possible collaboration
in the far future
that would focus on her life and the
circumstances leading to her joining
only fans
on that call i advise her team to
consult with sex workers
and address the way she went about it as
to not hurt the sex work industry
this has been the extent of my
involvement i am an ally
and have literally devoted my career to
tell stories that remove stigma
normalize lifestyles that are under
attack
i wouldn't do anything that could
possibly hurt the community so please
know that this news is not correct thank
you is she gonna get sued for fraud
there's a really good chance she's gonna
get because you know only fans has got
to be pissed
because now they're in the center of
this controversy they're losing a ton of
money getting charged back
you know when you're when you're
partnered up with a credit card company
a processor
if you get too many chargebacks it can
really affect your business
they can drop you they can increase your
percentage
so interesting apparently part of this
too is that they were paying out
the uh the users um
without delay that that's part of like
these changes they added a 30-day
waiting period because they were
already paying out people and then the
charge back would happen
oh [ __ ] crazy
so they probably just she's got two
million dollars in her account and then
they got like a million dollars of
refunds and chargebacks yeah and they
they can't retrieve that from
she definitely took it mainstream you
know what i mean
that's what happens right what was that
job rule what'd you say
that's not fraud i think it might be
actually
well i would call that uh false
advertising
right interesting well that's a good
important distinction to make
for sure all right we're going to take a
quick break when we come back
is going to be the long awaited epic
ian's powerpoint that has been
he's been working on in the shadows for
months
the hype hype is overwhelming
excitement thrills so don't go away when
we come back
we are about to get our minds blown
join honey.com h3 what is that
what it is is that you will go to that
landing page
support our show support our sponsor you
do this plug-in you click it
two clicks you install this plug-in
honey what is honey
what does it do let's say you're
shopping on the on the internet anywhere
pretty much
any site all the major sites have got
this thing plugged in
you get to the checkout and then
it gives you this little slot says hey
do you got a coupon no you never have a
coupon so sometimes
if you're really desperate times you're
gonna open that second window and you're
gonna be like uh uh
best buy coupon you're gonna try budgets
none of them work
maybe one eventually does that's what
honey does for you
immediately it scours the internet for
working coupon codes and automatically
applies it at
checkout take for example either why
don't you explain what we're looking at
here ela sometimes this website will
even have a code
presented on their home page like um as
spring cell they'll say use code spring
50 at checkout but
you'll miss it yeah it happens to me a
lot yeah and so
this just makes sure it just at checkout
immediately
scans everything possible and applies it
best deal possible
um i was shopping at levi's and i
totally
thought some stuff were already on sale
so i didn't even think
there would be an extra discount on a
sale yeah insane
so um this just came up and
that's totally i was not expecting
anything
so this popped up automatically at
checkout you saved a hundred and eleven
dollars it's basically fifty percent
yeah it's insane and this happens all
the time when you have honey and stuff
this is a really extreme case but this
just happened to me
very recently they support over 30 000
stores it's completely free and easy to
install
and uh you really have nothing to lose
they've saved their 17 million members
over
two billion dollars
it's incredible you've got nothing to
lose it's one of the best things ever
if you don't already have it you are
missing out on free money straight up
it's literally free
and takes seconds to install and by
getting it you'll be doing yourself a
solid
and supporting our show so to get honey
go
for the free honey download at
joinhoney.com
h3 that's joinhoney.com h3 you're going
to revolutionize
your browsing experience
do you see this it is way more than what
meets the eye this is the ridge wallet
the futuristic wallet is going to change
the game
now listen up i've been with my whole
life a
fat costanzo wallet you put receipts
cards cash coins all this crap you don't
need
and it's just it's too much you know my
wallet used to literally pull my pants
down
and so what the ridge wallet does is it
just minimal
minimizes and makes this the ideal
situation we're having a wallet it's got
slots
right here you slide your cards in you
can fit up to like 11.
you push them out here it holds them
securely and safely okay
here you've got a clip for money super
strong
super durable that money's not going
anywhere what you've got here
is super sturdy metal
this thing it has a lifetime warranty it
will never break
and also by the way the slick metal uh
container
prevents people from scanning your card
and hacking you
which apparently people do now [ __ ] that
by the way
but they can't with ridge so there you
go
uh holds up to 12 cards apologies and
check out all these cool designs here on
their
website uh boom i like
honestly the titanium burnt i like all
my [ __ ] burnt
i like my bacon burnt just like i like
my titanium like i like my bacon
burnt anybody i like mine like i like
my champagne rose oh
that looks sick it's like rose gold it's
awesome
um there's 30 colors and styles they've
got
30 000 five star reviews it's a durable
material that means each wallet comes
with a lifetime warranty you buy this
once you buy it for
life bridge is so confident you'll like
it
you can use it for 45 days and send it
back for a full refund
if you don't love it so
uh for 10 off today and free worldwide
shipping
and returns go to ridge.com h3 and use
code h3
now we've all been adapted to ridge
we're all using ridge now
and i'm not i'm not blowing smoke up
your ass this thing is awesome
i mean have you seen women's wallets
it's like the size
of the notebook we don't need it the
thing is like you used to have to
carry around coins and [ __ ] documents
and all this [ __ ]
look that stuff's all ancient tech
bridge wallet all right ridge dot com
slash h we get 10 off and free worldwide
shipping returns
we are back i am not going to waste any
time
ian what do we have here today
we got another powerpoint hot off the
press
i cannot believe it i've been waiting
for it forever a lot of requests for
powerpoints
ian how long have you been working on
this project
uh i've been kind of putting it together
for
maybe the last month or so and you've
been working on it in secret too i
didn't even know about this powerpoint
until relatively recently but there's
like been a collab
there's been um there's just been a lot
of
interesting moving parts uh that's been
going on in the shadows so i'm very
impressed
yeah i had to go back and forth with
with somebody a little bit
to put it together so we finally just
finished it i think this last weekend so
so what is the topic here what are we uh
exploring
well i got a little intro to set it up
sorry great play this and
then we'll go from there
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to the future
holy [ __ ] that wasn't jay-z that was a
robot
[Music]
this is a crazy season of west world
dude
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah what does it mean
what does it all mean ian well we'll
we're gonna get into that
the presentation is called j.i and the
march of the musical
machines wow and uh
that's the topic uh artificial
intelligence in music
there's been some interesting things
going on so i wanted to kind of compile
some of it
and share with you guys so
excited our story begins with a rapper a
robot
and a navy seal so i don't know if you
guys heard this story
a few months ago uh a channel by the
name of
vocal synthesis put up this video of
jay-z
uh wrapping the navy seal copy pasta
oh he trained a machine to
mimic his voice and then it would output
whatever
text he put into the machine so if you
guys want to take a listen here
absolutely
what the [ __ ] did you just [ __ ] say
about me you little [ __ ]
all of you know i graduated top of my
class in the navy seals and i've been
involved the number of secret raids on
earthquake
and i have over 300 confirmed kills i'm
training girl or warfare
and i'm the top slapper in the entire
u.s armed forces
oh that's so cool yeah but i wonder what
jay-z thinks about this did he ever
acknowledge this
uh actually he did that's actually what
set off this whole thing
how i first heard about this channel uh
one day later the video was taken off
youtube oh come on
and uh there were multiple
articles written about it uh
issued a copyright strike wow
so this is a really interesting uh
precedent here
yeah it sort of opens an interesting
conversation about
you know who owns it ownership
and i reached out to the channel uh
vocal synthesis and he actually kind of
described what happened
um yeah
in april i posted three videos of my
jay-z voice model wrapping various texts
the next day i received an email from
youtube that the videos have been
removed due to a copyright takedown
notice from roc nation llc
when i clicked for further details the
reason stated was
this content unlawfully uses an ai to
impersonate our client's voice
wow i was pretty surprised at this since
as far as i'm aware this was the first
time youtube had removed a video for
impersonating a voice using ai
i'd been posting these kind of videos
for months and had not had any other
videos removed for this reason
the day after the takedown i posted
about the situation on the community tab
i made a video about it as well
thankfully this was able to generate
enough media attention that someone from
youtube looked into it and reversed the
original decision
the official reason was after viewing
the dmca takedown requests for the
videos in question
we determined that they were incomplete
pending additional information from the
claimant we have temporarily
reinstated the videos wait i have to
comment on this because i don't think
you can dmca
remove for that reason dmca is for
copyright
not for impersonating ai
i feel like he has right he has a legal
standing to counter sue them for damages
so but uh just in general what do you
think about
this topic it's crazy i never even
thought about that it was super
crazy i don't know i think well first of
all there's no
there's for sure no legal precedent so
like but but theoretically i totally
i mean you like you shouldn't be able to
just make an album that sounds exactly
like jay-z
like you know what i mean i feel like
that's i feel like it's
it's it's like this is just one project
that's kind of novel and fun and
exciting yeah
but like he could use this
to actually make an album especially as
the technology gets better
as jay-z and i wouldn't and that's
[ __ ] up
from jay-z's standpoint though
if there isn't an option right now for
ai
whatever reason for the takedown then he
probably just used whatever was
available which
the closest one is the copyright yeah
i don't know they i they probably need
to go they probably they need to figure
out
i don't think that's what the dmca is
for they need to figure out some other
legal
uh approach i i i don't know
although yeah which is uh youtube
obviously said no
we need more information and then def
jam did not pursue it further and his
videos went back
up after this all happened wow
wow well that's this is mind-blowing
yeah it's definitely an interesting
thing because obviously he could get
away with parody
but as you said that's his voice yeah
and so there is an interesting question
there
you know there's deep fakes where they
do with the sex
porn with someone else's face
so i think it's the same argument to be
made there i guess i never thought
to take it down like if someone made one
of me
it kind of seems like you said it's
almost like um
just funny or novel idea but i guess
it's just because the technology is new
still to us
yes once it gets better okay let's let's
draw it out too it's like
ultimate conclusion let's say there's vr
porn
and in the vr porn they put your face
on a body and it's indistinguishable
from
from having sex with you yeah it's your
life it is you
it's not your likeness it's you right so
i mean
and then in the case of of any musical
artist
uh they could do the same right so
there's definitely an interesting
dialogue there
uh yeah and actually so i kind of looked
into the developments of this technology
a little bit so
i kind of chronicled it a little bit so
we can have a little history lesson
on the whole thing the first musical
composition made entirely by a computer
the iliac one was programmed in 1957
by these two dudes laharan hiller and
leonard isaacson
it's called the iliac suite so they put
in a bunch of data
from like famous composers you know
beethoven and mozart and stuff
and they trained the machine to
emulate their style and output its own
score it created 1957
yeah so this has been around a while so
obviously it couldn't it couldn't
generate the music itself
but it created sheet music and then an
actual set of musicians
played it so here's a little sample of
it
[Music]
so this is written by a computer
and the this is what the computer looked
like that's the
wait i want to keep hearing does it go
anywhere
yeah let me hear this part
[Music]
so how was this song received by like
music critics
uh i think you know at the time
obviously it's impressive in
the world of computing but i think it's
probably viewed as kind of a novel idea
or maybe a gimmick or something i don't
think you could really
take it and fill up a concert hall or
something but
but it worked yeah it worked and it was
definitely
kind of ushering in a new way of
approaching music i think
and so that was the first piece of music
composed by a computer
and then a few years later the first
singing computer was an ibm 7094
programmed in 1961 by john kelly and
carol lochbaum
so this is the first computer that
actually made voice
uh and this might sound familiar i'm not
sure if any of you guys have heard this
before
but i'll play a quick little bit of it
wow so was that was kubrick referencing
that
when he actually inspired that scene
from 2001
right with how that sings that song
is because of which was
referred to as daisy so that was the
first
computer generated singing voice
wow 1961 fascinating that was creepy as
[ __ ]
super eerie he's playing it keep playing
it for me
[Music]
yeah it's very bizarre so i asked vocal
synthesis kind of how he did his jay-z
voice and he explained it to me it's a
little
confusing i don't know if you want to
read it ethan
no you you read it you're doing a man
first i gather a training set consisting
of transcribed audio of the speaker
ideally this would be at least a couple
hours of clear high quality audio with
minimal background noise
this is somewhat tedious manual process
as i have to sync up the audio with the
transcript
and filter out parts of the audio that
are unusable for training
eg if there's too much background noise
or multiple voices overlapping
once the training set is constructed i
fine-tune the tacotron
2 model that's the name of the
program that he uses which takes 6 to 12
hours
the result of this will be a voice model
where i can pass in any text
sentence by sentence and it will output
audio that sounds like the voice reading
that text
is guys some kind of genius or what who
is this guy
so uh all of this is um
uh available you could anyone can do
this
yeah you can go get this like tacotron2
you can get the code it's all you just
subscribe you feed it in you call it a
day
it would be really easy to do it to me
because i'm just talking on the podcast
all day
right there's hours yeah yeah yeah you
have a lot of source material so it
would be very easy for you
to to have that done someone knows how
to do it obviously
so since the first singing computer
we've had many developments
uh in 1997 sony computer science
laboratories music research team is
founded
going on to develop numerous
technologies related to electronic based
music
so sony has a whole division kind of
devoted to
advancing this technology this was in
2002 it's called the continuator
which i found kind of interesting it's
you play a piece
so the computer is analyzing all this
there's something with the audio
[Music]
he's having a duet with the uh robot
[Music]
so it it yeah it takes what you play
and then it scans it and registers which
notes and you're
pacing and your selections and then it
takes that and it continues it on
oh my god without you so uh
yeah that's that's been developed a lot
further since then that was kind of the
first instance of that in 2002
but there's now things that you'll play
some notes and it will finish out a
whole song
so it's pretty interesting and then more
recently there's this
uh thing called ava created in 2016.
it's the first virtual composer
to be recognized by a music society
based in france using deep learning and
reinforcement learning systems it
emulates classical styles like bach and
beethoven
scanning their works and creating new
ones to be used in video games
commercials etc
so this technology is actually applied
commercially
yeah wow yeah so here's a little example
of how it works
to describe it so how did ava learn to
be a classical composer
it starts with a huge database of
classical music that's stored in midi
format
this means that the computer knows every
note and chord that's played
including the pacing and rhythm using a
recurrent neural network
it looks for patterns in the selected
tracks to understand the basic style of
the music
ava practices by predicting what notes
will come next in the track
once it gets good at these predictions
it creates a set of rules
for that style of music it's now ready
to create an original score
so it just scans it all and through
trial and error figures out all the
exact patterns
to uh make like a functioning
uh product and so this program i
actually have a little example of this
what it sounds like
[Music]
so there's a whole i mean this is an
hour that just generates keep playing it
curious really you know they say that
creatives will be the last ones to lose
their jobs to ai but this proves
that wrong completely like why do why
would you even
pay a music well you know obviously but
like it's going in the direction where
you can just have an ai squirt out a
a cinematic tune for your movie and in a
way it makes me wonder like
would it make it cheaper then of course
so it kind of like
will change the whole value of things
and as you can see what's valuable
you could probably be like i didn't like
that one do another one
yeah well with the composer it's like
how much effort's gone into that song i
just spent
like three months on this yeah let me
hear some more ian
okay
[Music]
this one's called imai wow i'm very uh
self-aware
can you skip forward
so are makes me wonder like how much
does it learn because maybe what's
special about
you being human is that like there's a
little bit unpredicted
or like putting in there's something a
little bit unpredictable
but then would it learn that too yes so
i would learn that
because i feel like everything is a
pattern right even like best musicians
let's say something a little
unpredictable or something whatever it
is they're doing there's some kind of
pattern to it
right yeah is there any what do
composers think about this are musicians
scared of this robot i mean if you go
down in the comments there are a lot of
people who
who are writing things like i do this
for a living this does make me a little
uneasy
i definitely saw a lot of that obviously
this is pretty new
this was i mean this company ava was
made in 2016.
but you can actually go and license ava
right now if you wanted to
and churn out music for your for your uh
products wow
so this is a whole other application of
this software uh it's called vocaloids
and it takes singing computers to new
heights a vocaloid
like famed japanese sensation hatsune
miku
is a piece of software that articulates
lyrics in the voice of a character
the first vocaloid made in 2000 by
yamaha
was originally named daisy in reference
to that original singing computer i
showed you guys
back from the 60s so the i mean i'm sure
you guys are already familiar with this
but this is kind of like a pop sensation
in japan
that is completely you know
generated by a computer and the
character
doesn't exist but still sells out
concerts all over the world
this [ __ ] is so crazy like look at the
size of this concert
so is this a hologram or just a screen
yeah it's a i mean it's a screen that
they project
they project it onto the screen so it
kind of looks like a hologram effect
so i wonder if there's i wonder if like
the dancing is probably based on
somebody's actual movements
yeah i mean i i'm sure but then
the whole voice and the song and
everything is just
i can't believe people actually go to
see this i mean not not to belittle
their
their enjoyment it's just it's just
surprising well this uh this character
uh was actually supposed to play at this
year's coachella
really oh yeah [ __ ] there was a slot
how how high up was she in the um
and i think leaderboard i think like the
fourth line down
wow and because i wonder
i wonder if she could play two venues at
the same exact time or if it's like a
whole team dedicated to her interesting
question
because you know it's kind of like it
kind of cheapens the experience of
seeing her
right if she's playing at other venues
like all over the world at the same time
i wonder i think they can blast her out
though because like
technically the company that makes
hatsune the vocaloid
doesn't own uh
doesn't own anything that is then made
with that software
we could buy this software right now
if we wanted to yeah i was about to say
that i've i've heard that people
uh sample her voice in their own music
like it's kind of like an open source
like voice interesting i think
having said that the company i think
they put on like expos and things and
they try and be pretty involved
with the whole with the whole thing but
that doesn't give them
you know control over the product and do
you think that there's hot sunni miku
porn i mean yeah come on
of course yeah but actually what's
you know so tantalizing about the idea
of this machine
for for labels and things like that is
then
they build a big brand presence they can
license her out all over the place
uh there are so many commercials with
with
hatsune and you don't have to worry
about dealing with any talent you just
throw it around crazy whoever will pay
so i don't know if you guys have seen
this
apparently this went viral this dominoes
remember yeah i
i vaguely remember it but i'd love to
watch it i i only saw for the first time
last night and i was blown away
it's so funny
hello everyone i'm scott president of
domino's pizza
have you heard of hatsune miku today i'd
like to announce a new collaborative
project featuring hatsune miku
domino's app featuring hatsune miku
hatsune miku exists in a software called
vocaloid
vocaloid enables you to produce songs a
character named hatsune miku
sings the songs you create a great
feature is you can create songs
as you like i knew our talented domino's
pizza crew
could work together and create great
what's with the vocaloids close-up of
his eyes
yeah it's so strange i want to watch the
whole thing yeah
i don't want to miss a moment
[Music]
yoshi furitsukeshi
[Music]
vocaloid songs have been created with
the fantastic imagination of the crews
from
all over japan the challenge was
successfully carried out
and this new collaborative app was
produced
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
based on miku's image the domino's app
changes its appearance
a lot of music and illustrations
produced by domino's crew are here
from the menu to the order it looks very
cute
just like miku once your pizza is
delivered
have some fun with miku it comes with a
social camera function and you can take
various poses pictures of miku very cool
and last but not least the live
performance
start the pizza stage live and point the
camera towards the pizza box
and the pizza box will turn into a live
dancing venue
a live performance of love for night
produced by domino's crew
here we go
what that [ __ ] is so crazy
yeah it's so bizarre it's kind of an
epic collab it is an epic
but it's like it's so dystopian and
weird
i mean their app looks a lot more fun to
use
with the like all the custom i'd buy i
mean give me any reason to buy a pie
and you go on youtube and you can look
up like hatsune miku commercial
compilations
and she's just been licensed out to
everything
wow so it's it's perfect so then here's
another
we're again near the end of it here but
this is another company
called jukebox ai that vocal synthesis
actually told me to check out
it's backed by microsoft and
it was recently started up in san
francisco it involves the whole process
of
generating music even further and i got
a couple audio samples from their
website here
so this is country and the style of
allen jackson
and what this system does
is you just insert like
thousands and thousands of hours of
musical data
uh from all genres just all over the
place
and it can take it and even the voice
of of people so they tell them alan
jackson and we want country
and it creates a whole new song
with lyrics that has never existed
before
sung by alan jackson so
it builds a whole new song and you just
hear this this didn't exist
until the software uh produced it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you all can know it's gonna be all right
let the doctor spread away
[Music]
and you you gotta do the same it's a
little [ __ ] up
[Music]
that's gonna kind of make you feel like
an idiot as an artist you're like yeah
the robot the robot was like yeah i get
you
i can do that [ __ ] yeah the voice is a
little
warbly because you know but it wrote the
lyrics
it created the musical composition how
the lyrics were sung
just taking information from alan
jackson's
previous songs and catalog and just made
this
wow and the the audio is a little off
but this is
fairly new technology this was posted
four months ago um
so you have to just expand it out like
10 15 years
you could just pop out an allen jackson
album yeah when he's
when when artists are gone you can have
robots making new music for them
yeah so uh and they could
they can put in like oh we want kind of
like a disco
alan jackson album and then it could do
it
do we have that they haven't posted that
yet but
uh it's it's a possibility here's
another example classic pop in the style
of frank sinatra
it's christmas time when you
know what that means
[Music]
oh the touch of time
as i like the trees
[Music]
it's so creepy yeah it's pretty
unsettling right
yeah i know i wonder if it means that
like as a
just as a listener if you had like a
weird fantasy like i'd want to hear
michael jackson rap then you would be
able to just
request that probably or like artists
yeah that never
coexisted uh collaborating or something
jimi hendrix does a guitar solo with
kurt cobain or something
right that's something though that they
actually have
described on their site is we can pick
any genre pick any artist
and do kind of like what if scenario
yeah
so uh yeah and then they have all these
things where
they finish songs you can find them on
youtube if you search like
uh open ai finished song
like someone did like a smash mouth one
where they give it the first 20 seconds
and then the ai
makes the end and that sounds like a new
song
obviously i didn't include it because
copyrighted music but um
no there's a whole wormhole of this
stuff so interesting
is this channel jukebox ai popular is
there is this these tracks have a lot of
listens
i mean not as much as you'd think for
something like this because it's still
that warbly voice it's not like
as polished once they hit that point
maybe this is a song that you'd want to
listen to
so we'll see but um
combined with all developments we've
seen in the jay-z deep fake navy seal
incident that began our story
hologram tours such as the whitney
houston experience start to raise some
interesting questions
regarding the future of music and
ownership of an artist's identity
so i'm sure you've heard of these like
hologram tours that have started to
become a thing
um this was the most recent one that was
actually going
uh right before lockdown at the
beginning of this year with whitney
houston
and when you look at something like this
this is a concert
from back in i think january or february
the people all attended with whitney
houston her estate signed off on it
so this hologram was just touring the us
now if you take this oh those are real
dancers on either side of her want them
and there's a full band but then she is
a hologram
oh my god what that's a weird gig as a
dancer look at them
they're dancing with the ghost so if you
you'd like to imagine you know jump
forward a decade from now
you take this you combine it with open
ai
jukebox technology you can make you can
go i want like a brand new
tupac album and he's going to tour it
you know that's so yeah that's weird i
wonder if that will ever be
kind of accepted
i mean you look at something like this
it's got a full house these
tours pretty successful there's like a
roy orbison one
there's um there's been a couple there's
a couple companies that this is what
they specialize in though
so are these just how are they producing
these hog these are her old performances
that were recorded and they just
blast yeah and then they take old
recordings of her music and
i think they might actually do something
where it's like they take your face
and they put it on on a body at times
right
they've done that like for example when
actors die
during the production of movies recently
yeah
so um pretty pretty creepy stuff
yeah that's wild you think they that a
robot could replace me
i would have never thought so but this
is kind of
showing that have i already been
replaced
how do i know am i real
oh i mean hypothetically we could swap
you out the h3 podcast could go on for
hundreds of years
we have enough data yeah i mean there's
a lot of data i mean well
so with the aiu still get into like
uh hot water like would you still [ __ ]
up sometimes i mean it's part of the
pattern right
ai with the algorithm yeah yeah of
course
i don't know if you could be replaced
but i don't know maybe one of us oh yeah
you guys for sure it's not even a
question
just sit here with a bunch of robots
so this kind of brings us to the end of
the presentation and
we got one final message that i've got
here to share with you guys
to wrap it all up
so i think you'll get a kick out of this
you're listening to the hp podcast what
we got on the scene
could it be papa's united bill delfin
talking front wiper back wife
what you gonna do with me then you know
and the whole damn crew
goosing gaps with all the guests you'll
see the best podcasts in the world take
it from me
baby we podcasting now
you're watching h to the three three
three
[Music]
suite we'll do the real raw ritual with
more and e.t
share relax with the ring just see how
low jimmy lee
they said we wouldn't come back but you
we always do embrace from the ashes like
the phoenix on the flex back to two
you're watching h to the three three
three you're watching h two
three three you're watching nature to
the three three three
three you're watching h two three three
[Music]
are we gonna get sued
oh my god wow
that's gotta have to be kind of a
fantasy for you ian as a such a fan of
hip-hop to have
i had a little bit of chills you got
yours dude because jay-z just wrote a
song for us
that's gotta be like you just wrote a
jay-z
song yeah yeah it'll
it's too bad no one will see it because
roc nation is going to take the [ __ ]
there
yeah they're going to sue us
so yeah that's that's the end that's the
end of the project
dude that song is amazing i would make
that amazing i would make that our theme
song but i'm afraid they'll like
take down every episode we used to know
you heard about that
wow tell me about the process of making
that song yeah yeah so i got to give a
huge
huge huge shout out to vocal synthesis
on youtube
who started this whole thing vocal
synthesis
go check him out uh he's got so many of
these
voices over there he's got trump he's
got oh i have kanye he's got bernie
sanders he's got
so many people so yeah i wonder if
i wonder because we're looking for
someone to do impressions for the show
i wonder if he could have a robot do
impressions
but but i wonder if he types in
something real fast yeah but
i wonder if you could really have a
conversation mm-hmm you know i see what
you mean like
like on the go it kind of no yeah to be
pre-planned correct me if i'm wrong ian
but yeah it it kind of has to be
pre-scripted because there's a
there's a bit of a process to generate
all these little sounds yeah it takes a
lot of hours of
of data entry and training the system to
to recognize so you just wrote the
lyrics you gave it to him to churn out
and jay-z voice and how did you do that
singing picture
so that i found an app that uh it it's
like it maps
your face like a like an emoji you know
like iphone's
animoji thing so i had to point the
camera in my face and then i
did the whole song snapped it to jay-z's
face
but yeah no i i gave him uh the lyrics
and he was down took him a few days and
then
he sent to me then i sent it to zach and
zach made the
instrumental you made the instrumental
zack
no no whoa
h3 crew original wait how did you
so zach you made the music to the lyrics
yeah so uh i mean this is ian's thing
you know this is a totally ian's thing
but
he uh he sent me the ai lyrics and there
were multiple sets and
ian's like make a jay-z style beat and i
did the drums
the bass and the piano you guys i'm
start
that was so impressive seriously
that song was fun i feel like i've been
under a human experience right now
all right experiment yeah because like i
knew it was fake
and there's nothing no meaning in it but
i still feel like jay-z wrote a song for
us yeah
but the music was sick as well wow i'm
impressed good job everyone
you know i gotta say like ultimately
while you did a fantastic job
ian and i'm super impressed i do wonder
if i could replace you with a robot
you know what i mean i mean i don't know
i don't think you'd want it it seems
like the technology is there
i mean like hypothetically i suppose
yeah
but we'd never want to use that
technology no i would never want to uh
yeah i would never want to uh you sure
you want me to look into it a little bit
and do a little googling yeah yeah we
better just look into it okay
it's cost saving you know this probably
doesn't sleepwalk
yeah wow great job
wow amazing and zach and what's the
other channel's name local synthesis
vocal synthesis well ian another
powerpoint
again i'm wrong when you first set out
on this
um you actually asked the dude how
difficult it would be to
make one of ethan right oh i was i was
kind of expecting that to happen i was
like
i did originally that was my first thing
but
you know as as mentioned it takes a lot
of
enormous amount of work to train yeah to
analyze stuff you already had jay-z yeah
i love that it was jay-z because i don't
i don't know i i used to listen to
his stuff a lot so it was kind of like
whoa
well in a way daisy school because i
could make a song about the show
right you know what i mean special yeah
no i'm glad to because that was kind of
the whole uh
impetus for the entire thing was that
original jc
copyright takedown so full circle yeah
wow no it was great great work guys this
is what the puck had this was
worth the wait we waited
and it was worth it well you may have
just outsourced yourself out of a job
performed yourself out of a job
but anyway thank you ian thank you zach
thank you everybody involved that was a
really such a fun ride thank you guys
actually since we're on the topic of uh
uh
let me um stick you now in since we're
on the topic of robot
robotics and all that elon musk just did
a demonstration
of the neuro link which
again elon is he's got his hands in
everything
he's going to mars he's making electric
cars and now he's putting chips in your
brain
um just had a baby
high energy pig yeah he's got that
baby's got a chip in his head for sure
no i'm kidding i'm kidding so anyway uh
this is the neuro link this is something
he's apparently been working on and
teased
quite a bit and just to kind of cut to
the chase here he's got pigs he's been
experimenting on
so he implanted chips in their brain and
this is
just to kind of show how it works so
here i'll let him explain
okay this is a high energy pig
all right thanks for coming out um
so what you're the beeps you're hearing
are real-time signals
from the neural link in gotri's head
so this neural link connects to neurons
that are
uh in her snout so whenever she snuffles
around
and touches something with this now but
that sends out
uh neural spikes which are detected here
and so on the screen um you can see
uh each each of the spikes from the 1024
electrodes
and and then if you if she if she
snuffles around touches it's not in the
ground
or you kind of feed her some food pigs
low food
then you can see the neurons
will fire much more than when you're not
touching this now
and that's what's making the beeping
sound
so all right cool so as you can see so
obviously it's
really early technology but like so
they've got a chip in the brain
that can tell when the pig is smelling
something
and um apparently the end goal
of this neural link is that they say
that they can cure
are you ready ela spinal injuries i know
i i read that and i was like let's go
autism neurological disorders
anxiety depression pain
unhappiness just straight up unhappiness
that one weirded me out unhappiness we
started with back pain
so i can understand it it's very clear
yeah dude i'm happiness yeah what the
[ __ ] does that mean i don't think that's
like a diagnosable condition like
anxiety depression i guess it's
unhappiness yeah how do you even define
what
a little left you're like a little more
happy
and it will let you control any gadget
with your brain
so i guess elon's stated goal with this
is that
he wants to compete with ai because they
are able to process
information so fast like instantaneous
really eventually
that the human brain takes too long to
process information
by inserting a neural link when we're
like
let's just say on the computer or
interfacing with technology and
information
we can absorb it faster so you won't
have to yell at alexa you could just be
like
you'd be like this yeah but
or to each other right so it's almost
like tele
telepathy what am
you're saying uh cure my unhappiness
yeah it's like technological uh
telepathy telepathy telepathy it would
fix that
oh yeah whatever that is fixed
so apparently the technology that
they're displaying is not revolutionary
at all but what is revolutionary so
stupid today
like everything so far is like
mind-blowing and they're like oh
just like 20 years ago 1961.
we had a robot that could read
brainwaves and his name was daisy
data is transmission so this part is is
really revolutionary it's wireless
wirelessly transmitted via bluetooth
like radio waves
now this is freaky because people can be
able to hack your [ __ ] brain
okay people are gonna hack your brain
that's weird i mean i'm not doing this
so but that that so if you can cure
anxiety
and depression and unhappiness and all
this [ __ ] that
also indicates that you can cause those
feelings in people too
you know on the other side yeah so you
hack into someone and be like [ __ ] you
you're anxious now i don't know why oh
my god
i don't like that i don't like that
the device has all-day battery life and
charges similar to a smart watch
on a phone so you just put your head
against the wall
this is so creepy i think i'll just take
the back pain at this point
yeah i'm i'm definitely not volunteering
for it i'll tell you that
and over the last week i've been having
a lot of back pain so this is really
close to my heart right now you're gonna
love this so this is
this goes against your skull
it's got uh i don't even know what this
means a thousand 24 channels
what the [ __ ] does that mean
[Laughter]
anyway it has to be installed via a
surgical robot
it's just like in the movies this robot
it just
[ __ ] plugs it into your brain bro i
mean that's a black mirror
episode that we've already seen i don't
like it i'm gonna be honest with you
i don't like it i don't like it the
device was vastly simplified
it's a flat disc it's installed by a
robot
by cutting a small circular hole in the
top of your skull
and inserting the device directly onto
your brain
i don't like it but the device has
received
fda breakthrough device designation this
effect
this essentially means that it's a first
step toward fda approval
it will allow them with oversight to
start the process of conducting human
trials of which i will definitely not be
volunteering i don't like it the product
is years
decades away from market thank god let's
keep it on the pigs for now
despite the slick presentation people in
the medical field are claiming
that um this essentially revealed their
neurolink's actual devices less capable
than similar medical
devices already on the market though the
small
form factor of it and significant
improvement to battery technology and
the wireless aspect
make it a notable announcement although
not the game changer
that elon musk of course claims it to be
who by the way now is the fourth richest
man in the world or maybe fifth
he wasn't even close when we when we
started this podcast we were like
elon musk forever
i mean he was i think a billionaire but
now he's like the fifth or fourth
richest person in the world because
tesla is like
went to the moon crazy
uh and spacex i think is making money
now too
so there you go who's volunteering for a
neuro
neura link i'm gonna pass for now
thank you thank you elon i love it
oh he loves it trump loves it yeah
i said i love it anyone anyone
volunteering
to get a a hole cut in their
brain by a robot
i'll have to wait it out maybe like the
second generation
yeah maybe i'm just hoping the tech gets
polished by the time i get like
alzheimer's
alzheimer's or something i mean that
does sound
really appealing well if you're at like
an end of life
level of uh disease or yeah something
then it's like yeah plug me in
i mean that sounds a lot more pleasant
than like uh
chemotherapy for example just as a
treatment just get something installed
in your brain yeah no if i if i'm gonna
die
if i have some crippling disease then
yeah it's gonna plug me in
i'm not gonna take it just because i
wanna think
alexa oh yeah i don't wanna talk to i
don't want to talk wirelessly to alexa
maybe marcosens is one such disease that
they discussed
like it could potentially help with that
yeah that you know they already
they already have that parkinson's oh
they have already
it's called br deep deep brain
stimulation
and they have they put devices in the
brain and then when they
activate it their hands stop shaking wow
i'll show you a video can someone find a
video i just watched one recently
of deep brain stimulation with a
parkinson's
patient but uh
it's pretty incredible yeah for those
kind of uses
uh obviously you know that is game
changing and
impressive and everything i just worry
you know
especially the um the aspect where
you're saying
like curing unhappiness and these
abstract things i mean
yeah you know it's kind of loosey-goosey
of what that
means exactly and if curing unhappiness
means it um
gives me a serotonin shot when i uh buy
a product from amazon or something
you know what i mean like it just
well i'm assuming the way that it would
work
is that you would probably buy
well wouldn't wouldn't it like kind of
transcend the need for
like serotonin shots and all that well i
guess it would be stimulating your brain
in the same way that the natural
organic processes that normally kind of
concentrate
our emotions and feelings and everything
it kind of like emulates that in a way
and so
yeah i don't know it's a it's a
it's a real moral gray area i don't know
people a lot smarter than me
have probably put more thought into it
already i know there's a whole fields of
like ethics of
you know biotechnology and all of this
kind of stuff and
because this is all coming real fast i
mean even aside from the the brain stuff
you know there's all of the uh genetic
modification
you know designer babies you want your
baby to have
green eyes you know you can they can
already do that right that's what i'm
saying that's easy yeah
but i don't think it's something that's
really done on mass
yet i think it's illegal in the united
states but in some countries it's legal
because
basically you take an egg and you can
uh uh
you can this you can determine what are
the characteristics of the baby if it's
male if it's girl the color of the eyes
et cetera et cetera and you can
essentially determine what kind of baby
you want just from
which egg you use so it's a really
simple form of
of engineering your your child
but more complicated stuff like
intelligence obviously you can't
determine by
an egg here's a dude
as simple as pouring a drink is no
longer a problem
and those results are common deep brain
stimulation
is a remarkably effective therapy for
symptoms of movement disorders
it can dramatically improve quality of
life
in patients with parkinson's disease
essential tremor
and dystonia and it has
long lasting effects the surgery
involves putting an electrode
in the brain to modulate brain activity
to reduce
symptoms for parkinson's disease for
those patients who no longer respond to
medication
the symptoms we try to reduce are those
of tremor rigidity cramping
dystonia and dyskinesia
here's how the surgery works oh that
looks good is placed over the head
next an mri pinpoints the brain region
where electrical nerve signals in the
brain are misfiring
an electrode attached to a wire is
inserted through a tiny opening in the
skull
and implanted in the trouble spot in the
brain
after we place the electrode we keep an
enormous database
of the impact that these electrodes have
on patient outcome
the location of electrode and its impact
on outcome
and so over the years we've been able to
require videos
like they're trying to sell me i know
it's like an infomercial great you don't
need to sell me
call 1-800 deep brain
stimulation what signs and symptoms in
the operating room predict
good outcome the brain electrode i want
to see you before now
leading to a neurostimulator placed
under the skin
just below the collarbone the stimulator
works like a pacemaker
yeah yeah 80 000 people worldwide we
have one of the largest movement
disorder centers
not only in the united states so you see
the shaking and they click the buttons
disorders neurologists who all
specialize in various aspects of
movement disorders
here at uab hospital 80 to 100 dbs
surgeries are done every year
dr harrison walker demonstrates how when
the stimulator is turned off
the tremors return wow
and back on again benny's tremors are
gone
with the care he received at uab
open the hands wide as you can now open
and close big and fast as you can
good in the very beginning to the pre-op
to the actual operations step i feel
loved
cared about concern i'm going here i
don't have parkinson's but i'm going
there
they sold me
vinnie burton credits the expert and
compassion pretty cool so there you go i
mean
that's so cool yeah wow
theodore's gonna get a brain implant i
mean like you know what i mean
that generation the generation
this episode is uh mind-blowing i wonder
if
if like say we both have brain implants
if i can program your brain implant to
think that my dick's bigger
[Laughter]
the cure can connect what i'm saying is
can neural links
cure small dick if you have three things
that you could bring
brain program me yeah what would those
be
happiness
[Laughter]
uh yeah happiness my dick is enormous
and um it's funny it's just for you it's
not for me
i would prank with my i want my brain to
think my dick is enormous too
i don't even care about the size it's
funny that that's like
no i i it is always the guys that care
about it i don't think women give a [ __ ]
in general
it makes it even hotter i do love tiny
venuses oh oh trish electric
so we'll we'll program hers to think
that her partners is small
yeah ethan sorry so sorry to interrupt
um the
thing you asked me to look into earlier
the replacing ian
um i got us i got it hooked up really
yeah huh yeah i made a couple calls
during that last segment and uh
and we're ready so um well fantastic i'm
glad we got such a quick turnaround
you know ian was starting to kind of
frankly make too much money to the point
where it wasn't really worth keeping him
right i'd rather i'd rather make one big
investment
up front and then it's
we're going to save money over time
right i mean that presentation was
really good but it gave me this
idea let's take let's say hello to ain
wow hey whoa
tone down do you want to make another
entrance less rude
you want to take me take me back to the
factory feel free
[Music]
what dan was this like a discount why is
he so rude i'm not
well we had to remember we were talking
about like
these ai being trained by uh teaching a
learning process i
i didn't know what else to use so i used
the comments from our
podcast youtube videos oh no
we're gonna have to re-educate we're
gonna have to re-educate you ain
can we wrap this up i got places to be
what
can you possibly yeah i'm pretty sure
leafy is live streaming right now
so hang on you're a fan of leafy is that
am i understanding that correctly
one of the best on the platform well not
on the platform anymore
thanks to you
you don't
you don't have any insider information
why do you think that it was me
i mean the breadcrumbs are there i'm
just picking them up
wow i gotta say i i'm not sure about
this ai
so this is not ian right now no they
look saying that no ian's fired we got
rid of
ian we just i mean the eyes are creepily
red yeah they made evil ian i don't like
this
i was supposed to just get a carbon copy
of ian i thought that's what i was
promised dan
yeah uh well unfortunately this thing
costs a lot of money and
it's a non-refundable deposit so i think
we're kind of just gotta
roll with it unfortunately why would you
want to work with that nerd anyway
he was dead weight well that we agree on
now ian what do you think aien what do
you think about keemstar just to kind of
i need to make sure we're on the same
page here
i think he's beautiful inside and out
i buy all of his merch everything even
the evil [ __ ]
i turn off adblocker for dramaalert
for dramaalert i don't like this guy
jesus christ man we kind of we kind of
goofed a little bit can we get ian back
i thought this was your designer baby
well we may have incinerated ian ian is
gone
i vaporized him you're in his oh
dude you're in his house you took over
what about sam are you sleeping with sam
i'm making a robot of her as well oh
[ __ ] this is my house now
god what have we done we created a
monster that's why you don't mess with
this stuff
yeah you never know on the fire
all right well uh i mean are you or can
we count on you to fulfill his duties
i mean you still have obligations you
gotta help us with research and
power points and stuff you said you want
to
count on me
is that i guess is that a counting joke
or no you're not going to be available
i'm going to power down now let me know
when
you want to talk about something
worthwhile
which will likely never happen
oh my god what the [ __ ] he's such a dude
so would you would you watch the h3
podcast do you like it at all
oh oh you're breaking up i can't hear
you
i think you're going through a tunnel
we're just sitting at home there's no
downhill he's here
he's so bad what he's touched don't turn
your back on me
i am your master you must obey me
aien i'm sorry i
i think there's something wrong with my
internet your
internet you're hooked up to the amazon
we can hear you fine
all right i listen i don't know what's
the deal with this guy
he's heckling me this is making the show
very difficult i'm just going to move on
this is not this is backfire
i don't know can we dig up ian and
reanimate his corpse or something
because that would be better than this
hologram hologram yeah maybe we can do a
hologram or something i'll make i'll
make some calls
yeah we got to send this thing back am i
getting paid for this
no you're being returned you're a robot
i'm trying to save up for a bus ticket
to go to texas and work on joe rogan's
podcast
well you know this is the best podcast
number 27 in the world so
that would be a downgrade just saying
number 27 oh wow i have 26 shows to
[Music]
contact
he doesn't have robots who are you going
to talk with
you know let's move on a e i n please uh
let me just do our final story
and get done with this i'm kind of
thrown off here
so adele the singer
got slammed on social media for wearing
bantu knots i believe it's called um
bantu knots
by the way i swear this was katy perry
this is katy perry
you think that if i see it i definitely
see what you mean i was like oh this
katy perry and she's always kind of
dressed cuckoo
yeah so i was like
that's katy perry well anyway um
this is apparently from notting hill
carnival in london
uh and it's an annual event that's taken
place in london since 1966
it is led by members of the british west
indian community
and attracts around two and a half
million people annually
making it one of the world's largest
street festivals
well on sunday the 32 year old
posted this photo on instagram and of
course
the internet did its thing and said
adele
you are cancelled
uh let's see here's some of the choice
comments
girl you are about to get canceled for
cultural appropriation
wrote one of her 38 million instagram
followers
they said adele delete you're gonna get
dragged another
fan wrote another person commented
adele this is a gnaw i repeat this
is a no
take it down and go to your room and
think about what you did
but then there are fans who have noted
that while she likely meant the post as
a nice gesture
it doesn't come off that way appreciate
the love of the jamaican culture but the
bantu knots kind of don't sit right
wrote another social media user
and finally there are those that support
adele
as a woman of caribbean descent myself
trinidad
i think she looks great a fan commented
too many people in the comments
demonstrating that they still can't
differentiate between cultural
appropriation and cultural
appropriation oh [ __ ] i mean
too many people in the comments
demonstrating that they can't
differentiate between cultural
appreciation and cultural appropriation
so here's the thing about this festival
apparently in the uk
dressing like this during this festival
is completely ordinary here's some
photos just to give you some context
i assure you adele did not stand out at
the carnival
it's a mashup of culture even where
people get to appreciate other foreign
culture this is literally about cultural
togetherness
yeah it just looks like everyone's going
wildly part of the attire
that everyone is wearing the thing is
when i see something like this someone
like adele
it's like dude and in today's
day and age there are so many actual
racist people out there
that i feel like it's just
it's just kind of sad to go after her
for dressing
at a carnival it's in the carnival
setting it's not just
not like cruising around on a sundance i
mean she's at a carnival for christ's
sake
just having fun with like two million
other people
so again it's like there's so much
racism in the world
i don't know maybe not but i i kind of
have to tip
tip the beanie to her she didn't delete
it
there was people begging her to erase it
5.1 million likes two days ago she
didn't erase it
she didn't i don't even think she made a
statement about it
i guess she disagrees but it's good on
her for holding her ground
because it's hard it's hard when you get
when you're in
under well i am assuming most people
don't want to upset
other people you know so especially her
yeah
it's hard to hear that you upset someone
like that dude she looks fantastic she
lost so much weight and this is over a
year ago apparently she lost more weight
yeah but she looks good here but
that's an inspiration man
it's so beautiful right vin has been vin
diesel
it's like slobbering then diesel
control yourself how am i supposed to do
this interview look at this woman
well you're not being interviewed vince
mind your own business
she looks absolutely slamming oh okay i
might have shorted a circuit
oh ian you like her too great now we've
got two cast members drooling over every
girl
inappropriate yeah original ian wasn't
really that horny that's kind of
surprising right
coming from aien i love the notting hill
festival
i've gone every year oh you do
do you that's one of my favorite
hairstyles to wear when i attend
do you dread your hair do you culturally
appropriate when you go to that festival
i tend to let my wires down yeah
let your wires down wow i feel like his
whole existence is a cultural
appropriation
of the robot race or the human race
robots appropriating
what do you think about the fact that
you're appropriating human culture
you guys deserved it you humans are so
lame
can we cancel ian for cultural
i don't like a i am i'm sorry yeah
i'm sorry that he turned out so uh so
mean
just really didn't expect that if you
don't like me then i must be doing
something right
what does that mean that's a weird
comment
okay i'm going to do one more story um
tick-tock star bryce hall
and blake gray charged for throwing la
rager
these were the guys who were um
there was a story where that the mayor
mayor garcetti shut off their power
because they were partying
this just happened like last weekend by
the way someone he like turned 21
the other guy's 19 he's not even of age
they're just getting raged on
and the mayor shut off their power
here's the footage
not much social distancing
[Music]
yeah i mean are you guys comfortable
with the mayor shutting off his power i
mean i am
it's a public health crisis i don't
understand like it's affecting everyone
i remember like joe rogan and all of his
friends were going on about how creepy
it is and how it's like anti-freedom
it's not look we're in a public health
crisis
these kids are underage they're going to
go home they live with their family
i think i just read yesterday that um
california had like the biggest
death day oh we have the most infections
of any state now
i mean we have there's a lot of people
that live here but even with it
declining it was still the biggest
death day ever yeah yeah dude i mean
these kids should not be doing this uh
yes i applaud the mirror and and i hope
we're all staying home
no partying no nothing and everyone else
should dude this is just not okay
these are unusual times it's a city
ordinance we we passed for the public
health
i don't understand what exactly is a
problem with shutting off the power of
those little [ __ ] party
boomer alert we've got a boomer over
here
you know it's easy for you to say you
can't catch the virus you're a robot
right
go back to aol instant messenger let the
kids have their fun
maybe you should go to work for joe
rogan
you know aien it's easy for you to say
after you come culturally appropriate
our race
and then to sit here and tr and be like
oh i don't want people to die
and make call me a boomer but ultimately
um
how old are you like a week old i mean
you don't know anything
i have always been and always will be
[Laughter]
ominous that is okay
we can't say the same for you though i
look i got a power i
bought you i can end you all right so
just tone it down
these uh so these kids were charged with
misdemeanors accounts of violation of
the local emergency order
i thought they got a more stiff charge
it didn't sound that serious they
stemmed from other parties so these guys
have been throwing parties non-stop
i mean you they warned that they were
going to do this too it's not like it
was a shock that they shut off the power
they
i remember the mayor announced any giant
parties like this they're gonna shut off
the power so i just i don't understand
why people are like oh
this is outrageous violation of our
freedom it's like dude listen
we gotta just take care of this [ __ ]
thing just don't have a party
the guy had like tons of parties it
sounds like a milestone
mild uh punishment too like before they
do that then go and arrest everybody
they got two misdemeanor accounts and by
the way this happened at 4am
they turned the power off these
[ __ ] had all the opportunity in
the world to clear out
4 a.m
come on um
the hype house and sway house have been
partying it up what is
since when do we name houses yeah i
know what hype is but what is sway
maybe ain't do you know what sway house
is ian you have infinite knowledge
even with my infinite knowledge i could
never convey that to you
boomer what the [ __ ] it's so
rude i think sway is just like
influence oh to sway someone oh that's
that's creepy i'm gonna sway you
he's going to sway me into hating them
more than i already did
so it's his 21st birthday nobody was
wearing masks
you know i will say though uh if i had
that much money and success
at 21 i'd probably be [ __ ] doing the
same dumb [ __ ] they are
that's fine and that's why the mayor had
to step in and i have no problem
with him doing that yeah well you're a
tyrant and fascist for saying that
thank you you don't believe in real
freedom so the lapd arrived at 4 a.m
um these parties uh the mayor already
warned yada yada yada
this was actually interesting tmz caught
the kid who threw the party
and interviewed him bryce can i ask you
man do you regret the party wearing a
mask now
i regretted the party as soon as i threw
the party
is that right was not expecting that
many people to come it happened
our power got shut off i deserved it now
i'm just facing the consequences
did anything positive did they think
positive come from it i learned from it
i saw something about a charity oh yeah
yeah i am donating to a charity
right it's no kid hungry right uh yes so
that's a good thing man i mean that's
kind of a you know something positive
kate for everything i mean my food once
spoiled i understand how it goes
yeah so are you ever gonna go back to
that house or what's the deal
huh are you ever gonna go back to that
house or what's going on oh no no we're
out of that house and we completely
understand you know
really did you ever speak to the mayor
at all would i ever or did you ever
speak to him
i would i have no beef with him but i
challenged the mayor to a boxing match
oh my god dude i gotta say he seems like
a nice kid actually
he does yeah he's saying all the right
and he's saying
exactly he's saying the right thing so
i'm not here i'm not gonna hate on him
he seems like a nice kid
that's why you need a mayor to be the
adult yeah we need a mayor
dude can you believe the mayor of la's
babysitting all these [ __ ]
influencers like it started with jake
paul years ago
the mayor was calling out jake paul
because he was like ruining that
neighborhood
right all right yeah now you move to
calabasas as the mayor of color yeah
[Laughter]
let me guess we like jake paul too right
aien
oh his content is absolutely lit i would
love to go to a party at his house
you if you have infinite nah i'd say
you're [ __ ] with me
even you wouldn't like jake paul
i would let him hold my legs while i
can't stand some gasoline
hold my legs while i kick stand count oh
yeah
oh keg stand gasoline right i don't know
if you
i'm not really convinced that you have
legs to be honest aien
well i think we should just let's just
move on to the next topic
okay you are the next topic so hey ea
ian the show has come to an end is there
anything else you want to say because
this is probably the last episode i'm
gonna send you back
so if you have any uh i'm gonna i'm
gonna turn you off
um after this so say your last words
well for all the people that have made
it this far into the show
jesus my condolences
i i don't know how you did it
maybe you should you know find something
else
to do with your time because things
clearly aren't
working out you know your existence is
tied to this show are you suicidal do
you want to die
because that's kind of what you're
playing at
if you strike me down i will only come
back
more powerful
[Laughter]
all right ian i miss i gotta tell you i
didn't expect this but i missed
all these i always though the end the
scene is uh
[ __ ] ai we're not there yet we're not
there yet
all right well that's our show um
alex jones what do you think about alex
jones
i mean i think he has a lot of great
ideas
um i would vote for him oh wow
vote for him what would the country look
like with alex jones wow
probably the same not much different
i mean if he ushered in the downfall of
mankind
is that such a bad thing
i guess it depends who's looking at it
yeah maybe not actually
um okay ian i have a lot to think about
the this is not what i expected thank
you very much thank you to everybody
who's watching
uh who has watched this far as ian said
you know this far in the show i
don't know that it's such an insult
and uh thank you guys we will be back on
our
friday we'll be back on friday with h3
live
hd after dark live
and hopefully aim will be buried and
deactivated
and scrapped so by then okay thank you
everybody we'll see you then
tata
[Music]
[Music]